in washington d.c security is incredibly  tight right now just two days before  president-elect joe biden's inauguration  law enforcement and national guard  troops from states across the country  still arriving as mr biden prepares to  take the oath of office  though access to the public is limited  between the security concerns and of  course the pandemic  even 20 000 plus troops that are headed  to help  must undergo covet screening this is a  very very important day  in american history and we all have an  obligation to ensure that  it is as safe as possible for everybody  not only in dc  but across the united states as well